[Music]
challenges of multi environment
infrastructure let's let's just go
through a journey for a little bit talk
about how we get to multi environment
infrastructure well first you start out
with some devs if they have a laptop
they have some servers so you have two
environments dev and prod you push code
from your laptop into your servers
everything's fine for a little bit and
you got a bunch more developers things
get a little hairy you start to add some
tooling to make this a little bit easier
so you add some shared get repositories
to control your source code you add
Jenkins because you're no longer SS
aging from your laptop you let Jenkins
do the SS aging because you're smart and
then you add an identity provider right
you need to manage identity across all
these folks and have ways to control
what they have access to so we're
getting a little bit more complex here
but we also added another environment
here because we have a lot of developers
are trying to integrate their code so we
added something between development and
production we added the staging
environment so we see these logical
environments being built all maybe in
the same data center or cloud provider
next we start adding even more
developers we actually hired a security
officer which is awesome they started to
see a bunch of our database credentials
in environment variables and they
decided to add some more tooling they
added fashion Corp vault to manage our
secrets across our company then
eventually you decide to move into a
cloud provider maybe GCP how many folks
are already running on GP here yes love
you guys so you you add more logical
environments as well as you're
replicating staging and prod potentially
but you're also adding an entire
different physical location right a
cloud providers region on top of what
you already had and you might start
looking at you know going from VMs to
something like containers how many folks
are doing containers or kubernetes in
general yes a lot of you right welcome
so what are some of the challenges that
we see as we kind of go through this
journey well first we're deploying
different ways to different environments
whether they be logical or actual
physical different environments
we see that our environments like
staging and prod are starting to drift a
little bit they don't actually look the
same so we're seeing a lot more things
creep into production that we didn't
really expect as we thought
staging was gonna catch it we have
trouble managing access control there's
different ways to access different
pieces so you started doing broader and
broader permission sets and people can
have access to things that they
shouldn't have
you also have networking complexity now
you have to actually go and connect
these multiple physical environments
maybe through VPN interconnects things
like that things get tough you have to
manage IP addresses now finally you have
built up a lot of tools that maybe don't
work well together or work well with the
infrastructure providers that you've put
in place so you have to start
integrating these things you can't just
throw it all away sometimes you wish you
could but it's been baked into your
organization so you need to start
thinking about how to integrate these
things so this is kind of the view that
we had in in the last few slides we have
a lot of logical environments and some
physical environments that we're
thinking about what we want to do is
build a consistent platform out of these
so yes for self what is the platform
essentially everything except for what
the developer needs to do to push code
somewhere and get it running you want
them to be able to have the same
experience whether you're in 60
different environments or three
different environments they push code
they monitor some sort of deployment
process and then eventually their code
gets out to customers and starts
providing value how many folks have seen
this gentleman before call sky tar yeah
awesome
there's a tweet from Kelsey for every
single talk I've ever done and this this
is the one for this talk kubernetes is a
platform for building platforms right it
gives us the starting point to get an
abstraction across our environments and
now we're talking about how we can get
there with with kubernetes so you'll
have different layers to your stack
you'll have an infrastructure layer
where you have disks compute networking
they'll have a platform layer where you
have these tools that make it easy for
developers to get their code out into
those you know computers and networks
and so forth and then you have your
applications these are the things that
are actually giving value to your
customers and so here's kind of that
view of our old
our previous diagram layered into these
stacks so here we have kubernetes
providing an abstraction above
infrastructure in GCP that's our VP C
networks our load balancers our disks
monitoring logging all these things that
we have to in the past use individually
you can also use these across cloud
providers and even on Prem and so then
on top of that we use that kubernetes
api to deploy our applications and you
add tools like jenkins for CI and
spinnaker for CD you store your
repositories and get maybe get lab or
github enterprise and then you provide
applications to your users so what are
some of the benefits of using kubernetes
at that infrastructure layer well first
you get a consistent deployment platform
that provides you a single API or set of
api's that you can use to manage your
workloads right when you want to deploy
something you know how to deploy that
using an API or declarative API and you
get the same type of deployment process
when you want to upgrade it so a rolling
update or a blue-green you do that one
way across all of your environments
finally this is available this
kubernetes api is available as a managed
service across all of the cloud
providers right so you can instantiate
kubernetes clusters in each of them and
even instantiate them on print with GK
on Prem so now you have this one
workload API that you can point your
deployment tools at to build your
platform so now we've built this
platform we have this abstraction for
you know deploying to kubernetes but one
of the things you'll notice as you start
onboarding to kubernetes is you have
llamó in llamó in llamó and more yeah
how many folks deal with the MMO on a
daily basis lots lots of us right this
gets really challenging over time
there's a lot to think about there's a
lot of api's to know there's pretty good
API documentation out there but you need
a strategy for managing these manifests
across the environments so one way to do
this sorry to to kind of sum up what a
kubernetes application is or the
deployables it it's a lot of these
different API stitched together the pods
are dependent on a config map and a
volume the services depend on pods and
their labels
so forth and they're all defined as yamo
so what do we really want to do we want
to have some base configuration but then
we can add and sprinkle in some
environment specific configuration on
top of keep that minimal as possible
yeah create a deployable manifest and
use that to deploy to our clusters
whether that be through cube control or
through spinnaker or whatever this is
kind of our end goal with manifest
management one way to do this is with
helm do we have a lot of helm users in
here yeah so helm is can be seen as a
templating engine for kubernetes
manifests it's got a really large
community if you're looking for examples
of what it looks like to manage an
application with home you can go to hub
column that Sh there are over 500
applications that are deployable today
into your kubernetes clusters and you
can see what the patterns are within
there it allows you to use loops and
conditionals within your templates I'll
say that this can be challenging as you
are now in a turing-complete templating
language mode so as people add
complexity to your templates they're
gonna start to lose visibility into what
each change actually does and I've
experienced this as a chart maintainer
sometimes I just have no idea what a
single line change in a heart will do to
a larger kind of multi file thousand of
line of Y animal template right the
reason I first got into helm was because
it was really familiar for me I came
from the world of chef and ansible
and new templating pretty well and knew
how to work with it so that's where I
came from and it felt really familiar so
it's a good place to start for those
folks helm if we go to that kind of base
plus environment specific config plus
rendered manifest methodology that I
mentioned earlier
Helen allows you to define a template
and so you see those bracketed values
here on the left side I have my values
image and my values dot log level
template into the amyl and then I
provide what those I want those values
to be templated or rendered into and
then it spits out a template or a render
template for me I can use the helm
template command in order to do this and
it just spits out the rock kubernetes
manifests for me
another way to do this is using a tool
called customize and it takes a little
bit different approach
it adds patches to kubernetes manifests
so you bring a normal untempered
kubernetes manifest and then you apply
patches to that manifest on top of it
it also can provide tooling to add
labels across all of your resources or
add a prefix to all your resources you
might add staging to the front of all of
your staging manifests for example and
it makes it really easy to do that
another benefit of customized is that
it's baked into cube control as of 1:14
so if you install cube control 114 you
already have customized available and
taking a look at the model for customize
you see on my base I don't really have
any templating in there I could apply
this into a regular kubernetes cluster
and it'd probably work and then I add my
patches so here what's important to know
is that you have to tell customize which
thing you're patching so you'll see my
patch in the middle actually calls out
the pod my app pod and the container
that I'm gonna change and my change here
is actually changing the image from busy
box to busy back busy box called F and
does the same thing renders me out of
template so on the right side here you
see the customization configuration and
it's called a customization yamo and you
can see I add some common labels a
namespace that I want apply to all the
resources but the core of it is I say
where's my base or where my base
manifests and then which patches do I
want to apply on top of that previously
you might have done a cube control
applied a chef in order to use customize
you have a customization yamo in your
your local directory use custom control
apply - kay in the local directory and
it will render the and apply the correct
manifests the next thing I wanted to do
was show kind of an example of reusing
as much of your code as possible or as
much as you of your llamo as possible
across your different environments so
you can imagine a company that is a
heavily Java based or has a lot of teams
that are doing a lot of things in Java
so they create a base that is how they
would run Java
this may include setting some standard X
MX parameters we're logging some weird -
D flags
do Java but you have a lot of stuff that
you baked into this Java base and then
from there you have different
customizations on top of that Java base
that create an application base and then
from there that application base can be
customized further for each of the
environments that you're in so you're
trying to reuse as much as possible as
you go through so you really know how
much or what what the changes are gonna
be as you work your way through so now
that we have a bunch of gamal that we
could deploy we're gonna take it's gonna
bring on been good who's gonna tell us
all about how to actually deploy this
really good rendered manifest okay so
before we get too far down into how to
deploy let's remember where we came from
so back in day 164 or whatever Vic
showed us a picture kind of like this
and we were using spinnaker or Jenkins
rather to do deploy our code out from
our CI system into our various
environments and we probably added in
some chef for some ansible or something
like that to help us keep our
environment configs as stable and
similar as possible and then at some
point we said who this kubernetes thing
is really cool so let's do some
kubernetes and at that point your CI
pipeline is pretty similar to what your
application pipeline was you're just
changing from building application
binaries to images but what's different
now is how you do those deployments so
now you're using shell scripts to run
cube control commands to get your code
out to your various environments at some
point hopefully not too far from that
point when you're using shell scripts to
do those deployments you realize I could
really use a tool that's going to help
me see how my deployments are going in a
more kubernetes aware kubernetes centric
sort of way and that's where spinnaker
comes in so in spinnaker you get the
benefit of kubernetes awareness as I
like to say so you get visibility into
your replica sets information about how
your pods are performing if they're
healthy or not
in spinnaker your kubernetes clusters
our first-class citizens they're just
called accounts in spinnaker so
spinnaker knows about those things and
you can use resource annotations and
then even do automated rollbacks
to really manage your deployment
pipelines across all of your
environments so a sample spinnaker
pipeline might look something kind of
like this and it's gonna vary for
everyone depending on the complexity of
your applications
how many micro services you might have
but in general what you're going to do
when you start a deployment is to deploy
a canary so add a new version of your
application you're gonna test it make
sure it's working the way you expected
to from a feature functionality
performance standpoint validate that
thing and then roll it out to production
or to your staging of our whatever your
deployment target is the canary
validation could be a manual action
where you say looks good and you click a
button at some point that might
introduce too much latency into the
process so you might want to look at a
tool like Kayenta to automate the
analysis of your Canaries some important
things to consider when managing your
pipelines so treat your pipelines is
code I hope that there's one thing you
take away from the deployment portion of
this is that your pipelines in your your
CI CD processes are really just code
when it comes down to it so if you're
applying get ops principles to your
application code do the same thing for
your application deployment pipelines
and build processes try to leverage a
tool like Sto so that way you can really
understand where your traffic is heading
and how much traffic is hitting your
canary vs. you're running deployment and
then use the same pipeline across all of
your environments so whatever you do for
production deployments should be the
same kind of process as you for staging
QA whatever pre-production environments
you might have direction okay so in a
single cluster rollout we have our
shared tools cluster up there and you
start your rollout by going to your
staging environment deploying your
canary and once when it's validated you
roll it out from there same kind of
thing for your production environment so
you deploy your canary and then roll it
out from there on the the other side of
the slide are some deployment strategies
that you could use but typically you
find yourself in the rollout scenario
because it's more resource friendly okay
now let's think about this from a multi
cluster perspective so because
kubernetes is a cross-platform tool you
can be running gke clusters you can be
running gke on prim and you could be
running kubernetes in some other cloud
and that introduces several
complications to the to this scenario
here notice in the slide we have two gke
clusters that look pretty similar but
they're in different locations we have a
gke on prim with a different version of
kubernetes and another cloud provider
out there with yet another version and
you have to think about how your
application behaves in those scenarios
and then also about how your
interconnects are happening there
because they can introduce variables
into the into the scenarios so again
with spinnaker you can chain your
rollouts your deployments so you start
with a single cluster deploy your canary
to that one cluster and that one looks
good then roll it out to the rest of the
fleet in that cluster and then move on
to the next one
maybe you're monitoring and your tooling
is sufficient that you can do your
canary rollout every cluster all at the
same time but understand that that in
your
looking at the results from your canary
deployment in the context of many other
variables at the same time so but the
important part is to canary on each one
because those differences could have an
impact on your application and also to
use the same process for each cluster so
once when you have your application out
there you also need to be thinking about
how to manage traffic across those
clusters so sto is a good tool to use
for managing your intra cluster within
one cluster or across your clusters or
also known as your east-west traffic the
other thing that's really helpful to do
is to manage your north-south traffic so
how much traffic you're getting from the
outside to a particular kubernetes
cluster and tools like CloudFlare or
Akamai or fastly something like that can
help you manage that traffic and that
allows you to cluster to canary your
application at the cluster level so you
could do this upgrade that's shown on
the slide and know that that new change
isn't going to impact your application
so once when all things are in place
you're in a pretty good position to
handle changes to your environments and
to your kubernetes clusters for example
gke has this awesome little upgrade
button so when you upgrade it goes out
and it rolls out the changes the new
versions of kubernetes to all of your
masters and worker nodes and that's
awesome it's a great feature but that
also introduced changes in the in the
API and if that does cause a problem
rolling back is hard in that in that
scenario there could be hard but having
the ability to control those your
traffic flows and what versions of your
applications are deployed where is very
useful also in like I mentioned
previously kubernetes clusters are
built-in and first class citizens in
spinnaker so they plugged right in
relatively nicely Carl's going to touch
on this in a little bit about some of
the the nuances and challenges there but
they fit in pretty nicely and then also
don't forget that shared cluster up
there with all of your Jenkins and your
spinnaker your vault whatever those
shared tools across your system be sure
to treat all that stuff like codes keep
it in source control and also try to
store your artifacts from those
processes out somewhere else not on the
cluster that keeps you out of the pet
cluster scenario that we hope no one
finds themselves in and the coop the
Google Cloud Storage plugin is a pretty
good way to go about doing that so now
I'm going to turn it over to Carl thank
you I'm Carl and I work at Cruz and Cruz
is building self-driving vehicles to you
safely connect people to the places and
things and experiences that they care
about
so we're primarily building a
self-driving car fleet in San Francisco
right now
this is one of our open source tools
called world view allows us to see what
the car sees and be able to reproduce
its functionality so I work on the pass
team so I don't work on the car itself
mostly just on the cloud back-end stuff
a lot of stuff that I deal with has to
do with the multi cloud infrastructure
that we have at Cruz we have a hybrid
private cloud internet or network rather
that spans on-premise GCP and AWS we
have things on premise that need to be
on premise like ingestion from the car
data we have stuff in GCP that makes
sense on GCP like GPU and machine
learning and gke we have stuff on AWS
that we've had on AWS for awhile and
that makes sense on AWS based on their
strengths so this is just a sampling of
our sort of multi cloud infrastructure
and the variety of workloads that were
running that's kind of wider than most
places that I've worked at so in order
to make this work on GCP which I'm going
to be focusing on today we we ended up
our projects and our folders in order to
separate them on environment lines we
have environmental folders at the top
level of the organization in GCP and
then we also separate the networks along
those lines as well to provide isolation
between development and staging and
production so if if some1 compromised
development on some CI from open-source
tooling or something they don't have
access to the production clusters or the
workloads there so it adds a little
extra security a little reduction of
blast radius and what this means is that
we're setting up multiple projects per
team at this point so for example a net
inch here has a shared private network
spanning multiple environments and they
share that network with the other
projects and we have different teams
that have for example their their
databases in SAS products and other
things like cloud sequel other SAS
products in GC whether they're running
GCE nodes or GC pcs and then the past
team manages a set of shared clusters
across the environment here so in order
to make this sort of multi-tenancy multi
environment workload or spread work in
gke we also spread these environments
across the gke namespaces so we use GK
namespaces for a tendency that is not
necessarily full mate multi-tenancy but
also not completely uh nice elated
so we span these we have these clusters
in these different environments and we
have namespaces allocated to different
teams across those clusters so a
different team would use continuous
deployment for example to migrate their
application from development to staging
to production as it increases
instability so a couple of security
challenges that's presented to us is
that when you're not using one
kubernetes environment one gke
environment you have to figure out how
to make sure that your identity your
enterprise and identity provider and
your single sign-on and your service
accounts and your credential rotation
and your bootstrapping every project
works across those clusters and
effectively what that meant for us is
that we had to go from managing a whole
bunch of clusters to managing a smaller
set of clusters with having a platform
team that managed those so that we could
centralize that experience so that we
can level up the experience that
everybody had so there's some other
security concerns around encryption that
I'll get into in a bit but basically you
will need secret management and in
secret injection and some kind of
caching for secrets sometimes and you
need to manage TLS across your clusters
if you have it in more than one cluster
it becomes a little bit more of a
headache to manage externally so this is
this is one of the things you might not
think about when you start going into
multi environment is that multi
environment really probably means
multiple gke clusters and when you're
thinking multiple GK clusters you can't
centralized everything in the CRD level
you can't centralized everything in the
kubernetes layer it doesn't make sense
to store the source of truth and 1gk
ease secrets you probably want to
externalize those and then replicate
those to your gke clusters and then we
have a whole bunch of complications
around access control around group
management and role binding which I'll
get into in a bit and then also like
service to service authentication access
control is a little challenging user to
service user to platform user through
service all of these are things that you
might not think of right up front but
you'll have to solve sooner or later so
one of the things I wanted to focus on
that sort of challenges from the
security perspective is vault
infrastructure we chose vault early on
partly because we were already using it
and partly because we wanted to
externalize like I was saying the
secrets management outside of gke we do
like gke secrets but there are little
sort of coupled with namespace
permission boundaries and we wanted to
bind them externally to that so a couple
of the solutions that we targeted here
was a vault login through kubernetes
service accounts so you can use your
service account in kubernetes to log
into vault and that means you have to
authorize that service account with
permissions involved and that's managed
externally and then also if you want to
sort of go all the way into secrets
management here you have to get into
either secrets injection or secrets
caching we went with secrets injects
and that meant using this model on the
left which is a container that we wrote
or you can write pretty trivially that
basically reads from vault logs in with
the service account downloads the
secrets that are configured in
environment variable stores the minute
in them in memory volume so that they're
not written to disk and then the app
container slurps them in so this is a
little different than environment
variables because you have to read them
from disk but it's not too hard to read
those in from like a bootstrap or an
entry point in your docker file in your
container so basically that this lets us
do sort of a lift and shift where we
have a container that doesn't know about
vault and then inject the secrets into
it but an alternative way is to make
your container vault aware and pull from
vault at runtime that's also an option
which we have used in a couple scenarios
so GCP service accounts is another
integration involved that we've enabled
and configured which allows us to log in
from the container with my vault
credentials to ask vault for a GCP
service account and then it asks it for
specific credentials that are generated
with the time app so your application
gets credentials to tuck to GCP to for
example talk to your database in cloud
sequel or talk to your sequel in Big
Data or something like that so we use
the sort of host of this solutions and
there's a couple other ones there's like
AWS integration there's several other
pieces and vault is very powerful but
what this ends up meaning is that you
need to do a little bit of vault policy
management so we ended up with a sort of
convention around vault name spacing
that matches our gke namespaces which
matches our GCP projects and it means
that your applications are stored or the
secrets that the application use are
stored in vault in a place that is
namespace aware that's environmental
where and it's application where so what
this allows you to do is for example
have a team admin or team members that
go
and have permission to read and write
and delete secrets on all the
environments sorry and then you can have
other people with read permissions to
those that don't necessarily have access
to see them but you can just list them
to show that they exist and then you can
have the application that only knows
about its environments specific
credentials that way you're not leaking
credentials across environments one of
the nice things that this provides us
with is it means that our continuous
deployment solution doesn't need to know
about the application secrets it means
the application developer can update the
application secrets independent of the
lifecycle of the application and it
means that your continuous deployment
doesn't need to be authorized with volt
so a couple of lunges that we went to
I'll just sort of categorize and bucket
these image building and deployment is
sort of a problem we need to solve
everywhere and if you solve this in a
multi-tenant environment it's a little
more complicated if you solve it in a
multi environment scenario it's not
necessarily much different the way we
went with is having a GCR that's central
to the paths team that hosts GCR but
what that means is that because the
boundaries for security are around GCR
that means everybody who has access to
push or delete to that GCR also has
permission to delete other people's
containers that they pushed into that
GCR which is a little bit of a security
risk so you can either centralize this
or you can split it out delegate it to
the teams so that each team is hosting
their own but if you do that then you
have to install a pull secret on all of
your containers and if you're sorry on
all of your clusters and if you're
running multiple clusters that can be a
little complicated so around application
up operations some of the things that
that gke doesn't really provide you with
here have to be solved whether you're in
one environment or not that includes dns
configuration TLS configuration
structured logging will automatically
get converted by a stack drivers but you
have to actually emit structured logging
from your application using the right
metrics a library is also important for
stackdriver
and in our case we use data dog to emit
our logs the data dog because that's
where we were conventionally aggregating
all of our data and then around
lifecycle this is where we get back to
continuous integration and continuous
deployment the sort of templating and
cloud development environment we allow
people to develop locally but we find in
general people prefer developing in the
cloud so they have more resources
available it's more like production they
don't have to have a beefy machine they
can just do it on their laptop so we
provide a cloud hosted dev environment
we host a staging environment which we
allow use for both near prod deployment
and load testing and then integration
can either be spread across dev or
staging depending on where your CI is
located with the use of spinnaker you
can get approval gates blue green isn't
quite supported yet but deploy targets
is and then account management I'll get
to a in a minute so one of the solutions
you can get to for image building is to
use K native build we're not quite using
this yet but we prototyped it and one of
the things we like about it is that
unlike the rest of Canada if you don't
need sto to use the build portion of
Canada and so what that means is that
you can get a CR D to push builds as CRD
llamó files and you can do that from CI
and it'll push the build from
permissions that came in to build has
into your G CR and that means we don't
actually have to give out GC are pushed
to any of our developers so what we've
done is we have a dev GCR that anyone
can push to and then we have a project
you have to have a service account to
push to or push to from a build
environment another thing we did was
we've been using spinnaker for a while
and one of the things we realized that
it was a real pain to add new accounts
so when we got to this multi environment
multi tenant system and we had like
somewhere between 3 and 20 clusters and
then we decided you know I don't want
everyone to have cluster admin to deploy
into whatever namespace they want from
spinnaker we actually had to isolate
that down so now we're we're spitting
out spinnaker accounts by like 20 per
cluster which meant we needed a new way
to manage this because each new account
requires a reboot enough spinnaker
redeploy because the admin configuration
is in yeah mo or JSON actually under
hollered which manages a spinnaker so
what we did what was he wrote a
spinnaker operator and the spinnaker
operator basically just manages your
accounts and manages the lifecycle of
spinnaker itself so this is not yet open
source but we're leaning that direction
and we're gonna reuse it in production
for a little longer to make sure we've
vetted it right and then we're gonna
probably put in an open source in the
following months some other networking
challenges we ran into DNS I mentioned
Public DNS turns out to be pretty easy
but when you start doing private
networking or a hybrid private
networking you have to worry about
private zones which is like a brand-new
GCP feature and then private DNS from
the cluster you have to start worrying
about if you're going across
interconnects or VPNs you have to worry
about configuring the IP mask on your
Kube DNS or your accordion s depending
on your config and this allows you to
propagate the IPS from multiple networks
otherwise all you know about is the GCP
networks for ingress I'm gonna go over a
pretty complicated private ingress
solution in the future or in the next
slide and public ingress we mostly just
use GCL B however you have to supply
your own TLS and DNS for egress public
egress private egress sorry
goes through if you have a private
network it goes through your VPN or your
interconnects you have to set up your
cloud router to like basically configure
IP propagation across the clouds in both
directions which is a little complicated
especially if you start getting into
multiple networks per GCP and multiple
clouds and on prim and I'm glad we have
a net inch team
so public egress though we previously
deployed our own Nats with terraform
because that was the recommended
solution on GCP there is now a cloud NAT
solution that is beta a I think it's GA
and so we we are switching to that but
what it means is you have to put network
tags per your regions because if you are
in the same network
with the cloud net by default all
traffic goes to that cloud net and if
you have two cloud gnats in two
different regions they start egressing
across regional lines which is bad so
you have to start setting Network tags
on your nodes to make sure they hit the
egress traffic so this is just a few of
the little complications that we ran
into and hopefully we can avoid you from
running into them six months down the
line so I talked about private ingress
we have two of the three of the pieces
of this solution built out and have for
a while and it works okay but we're not
in love with it the GC PGCE cloud
provider here this is built into
kubernetes and it knows about GCP and it
configures the i'll be the internal load
balancer in GCP and that allows you to
do I believe TCP load balancing it's a
layer for TCP load balancing however
what we needed was an analogy or
something analogous to our public load
balancer which does TLS termination so
what we ended up doing was putting nginx
controller behind that so we have il be
routing to engine X and Gen X does
termination and then we handle the
traffic internally and then we're
working on deploying sto to do the
end-to-end internal encryption but the
last mile still exists you still have to
handle DNS like I mentioned there's an
external DNS project that we have on our
backlog to look into it can configure
the private DNS or public DNS in GCP for
configuring those but it becomes a
little more complicated if you have a
private network for example we've been
using route 53 for private DNS
resolution and that works great on AWS
but in order to get that into GCP we
have to route through the interconnects
to resolve all your dns connections and
that's a mess so we added up caching
that on the GCP side and we're looking
into a more like DNS mesh solution where
we have some Google clouds parts and
some AWS parts and they like mesh
together so that they have multiple
sources of truth for the DNS so external
DNS won't solve all of that together but
at least have helped you provide your
provision your private DNS so
the the benefit of this solution is that
all three of those components can be set
together with kubernetes configurations
so this is self-service to the user the
user can say I want private DNS or I'm
sorry I want private ingress but I want
public ingress and I configure that the
same time I deploy my application which
means that I as app as owner or a
cluster operator don't need to care
about how people are doing ingress I
provide some solutions and they opt into
them all these logs are available to
them and they can opt into them with the
annotation it's pretty slick so we do
have some operational challenges as well
when you are in multiple clusters
whether that's multiple environments or
multi-tenancy
we have to figure out whether you want
to aggregate or separate your metrics
and your logs so by default gke logs and
metrics go to stackdriver in the same
GCP project we didn't necessarily like
that very much so what that meant is we
had to give you permission to all of the
users on our shared clusters and we
didn't want to give them rate
permissions because they were our paths
projects and they would step on each
other's toes
so what that meant is we had to sort of
invent a solution that would emit
metrics or sorry logs to other projects
so we have a stack driver fluency
solution that will emit a duplicate of
the logs to the projects that they own
so that they can do log to metric
conversion and they can also do log
dashboards or metric log metric
dashboards for logging we mostly just
use stack driver for tracing we use data
dog like I mentioned for uptime checks
we use run run scope so one of the
benefits of run scope is that unlike
most things like Pingdom or other
external SAS providers that will do
checks of your applications run scope
allows you to deploy an agent behind
your firewall so we can do this in the
private network and it does a check of
your application so I'll say go talk a
little bit more about run scope in a
minute but about availability we also
provide a couple features of the paths
that don't come native which e ke that
includes
backups with ARC which I believe has a
new name that I forget we also deploy a
D scheduler which makes things evenly
deploy across the cloud and like was
mentioned note pool can be upgraded with
a click of the button on gke
unfortunately that only upgrades the OS
and the kubernetes version so if you
want to change the instance type or you
want to change node tags you have to do
your own recreation of the node pool so
we ended up doing was terraforming in a
Bluegreen deployment of node pools which
is a little complicated but it allows us
to do zero downtime deployments we have
to have like double the quota we
normally run which is kind of a hazard
but it works so a little bit about run
scope we deploy the agents on GCE and
also on gke we also wrote an operator
for this which again will probably be
open-source soon and this operator takes
currently ingress annotations so these
ingress annotations tell what endpoint
do I want to hit what back-end bucket do
I want to put them in and run scope and
then run scope will tell the agent or
rather the agent asks the the SAS
product like what should I check and
then the agent checks your applications
sometimes that's going horizontally on
the cluster
sometimes that's going out of the
networking back in the ingress path
sometimes that's going between clusters
depending on what you're trying to check
so this allows you to check your
applications from the full end-to-end
path including including ingress and not
just what kubernetes does which is the
the cubelet on the node checking your
your pod as you can imagine that doesn't
really cover much breadth of networking
and usually networking is the problem so
having something that will do a sort of
end-to-end smoke test for you every
minute or every five minutes is super
valuable so we plug this into our local
private networking and also a public
networking and we have that optional
we're going to be working on converting
this to a CR D in the future so that
it's not 5 annotations but that will
allow a little more complicated
configurations of run soap tests and
then
so the moral of the story here a bunch
of these operators that I've sort of
displayed and invented or worked with my
team to build has been about putting
your configuration for your operations
of your application where your
application devs can use it we have a
DevOps model at Cruz where every team
that is deploying or is building code is
deploying that code at least on the
backend and so all of our teams want to
be able to configure these things about
operations about logging about ingress
about metrics whether they know it or
not they need access to configure these
things self-service if possible so it
creates less operational overhead for us
and it makes things easier for them they
can just go look at the documentation
and figure out how things how to do
things and it makes it easier to do your
continuous deployment because your
continuous deployment doesn't need to be
coupled with all of these pieces they
can be independently configured this is
the link to our Cruz blog where you can
see those open-source announcements in
the future or I see our previous ones
already and thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]